scientists created the first artificial
elements during World War two and they
were actually classified at first and it
was only afterward that they were
allowed to announce the discovery of
these new elements when you're creating
a new element the basic idea is that you
have a target of something and you have
a beam of something else and you shoot
the beam at the target every so often
one of the beam atoms will knock into
one of the target atoms and the two
nuclei will fuse together and you'll get
a heavy element after that fusion occurs
so when you're deciding what atom to
shoot at another atom in one sense it's
very easy it's just arithmetic so if you
have element 100 and you shoot element
12 at it the resulting atom will be an
atom of element 112 the difficulty comes
in in that some combinations of atoms
depending on different properties are
very unlikely to fuse if you pick the
wrong elements basically for your target
in your beam it's very unlikely that
anything will happen so it's very very
difficult to tell when they have
actually created an atom of these new
elements and for the most part nowadays
they are discovering this fact
retroactively lease only after the
element has already decayed
radioactively into something else when
scientists are making these elements
usually three or so is the rule for the
number they need to really come in some
cases it has taken scientists up to nine
years of work doing it not every single
day but doing it for months at a time
right now scientists think that there
could be two reasons the periodic table
could stop first of all there's a very
prevalent theory that says that right
around element 172 some weird kind of
spooky quantum mechanical things might
happen where you're having electron
positron pairs formed and the nucleus
itself might start gobbling up electrons
and destroying them turning them into
neutrons but there's a lot of scientists
that think that well before the point of
172
the nucleus will be so unstable that it
will basically disintegrate almost
instantly around la 120 it's going to be
particularly challenging to make new
elements for a couple of reasons the
first and primary reason right now is
getting enough target atoms in order to
actually produce them and right now we
just don't have the technology to mass
produce enough of the target atoms after
120 the lifetimes of these elements also
keeps dropping even more so even if you
produce one it gets harder and harder to
detect them at this point so the island
of stability comes in because there's a
theory out there that says if you have a
certain magic number as they call it of
protons and neutrons those nuclei will
be especially stable and it's possible
we could see exotic and interesting
traits like that emerge as we start to
get closer and closer to the island of
stability one example of a new and kind
of exotic property emerging unexpectedly
is the element mercury so a
room-temperature mercury is actually a
liquid which is unlike the other
elements in its column and because
mercury is a liquid at room temperature
it has a lot of really useful properties
you can use it in things like
thermometers and barometer so a lot of
early science depended on this trade of
mercury we have created every element up
to 118 so we have a nice complete
periodic table up to the seventh room
the next new element that scientists
create will either be element 119 or 120
so that'll have to go on an eighth row
kind of by itself hanging out there
right now scientists are content putting
these new elements in the spot they
should go on the periodic table just
based on what their atomic number is so
based on the number of protons that they
have but we've already seen in a couple
of cases a few elements that deviate a
little bit both chemically and
physically their chemical and physical
properties from what they should be so
as we move down into much heavier a
comic
we'll probably see more and more of
these anomalies and then it will be an
actual debate do we put them where they
should go or put them more where their
properties say they should go the
scientists do think there are some good
practical reasons for trying to find
these new elements one is that the
technologies that they're developing to
create these new elements basically the
particle accelerators the separator that
detectors things like that can be used
in other applications another
application is things like Radio
isotopes for medicine a lot of the
accelerators and technologies that are
used to make those nowadays we're
pioneered looking for new elements but I
think it's just human nature I don't
want to keep pushing to keep going and
the periodic table does have this really
iconic place in science where it's
something we all learn about we all
remember it from chemistry class even if
it's the only thing we remember I would
bet scientists are never going to stop
making and trying to make new elements
on the periodic table
[Music]